Magnus two game points ahead you're  making this look easy  with uh with the tough  uh you both got short of time at some  point like I felt like I was uh pretty  comfortable for uh for a while slightly  better  um  but but yeah it's always  um it's always tough uh he always has  has tricks but I think I navigated it in  a decent way there was this moment he  went King H1 and you've got Queen H3  with this G2 Pawn pinned did you miss  that or did you not like it  foreign  oh  that's that  we thought it was a blind spot  but Bishop a oh my Bishop is on C6 yeah  yeah  that was just a blind spot okay that  would have uh that would have made it uh  easier of course uh but uh I mean even  the game was  was uh easily winning